you're seeing this in the schools this
was a story came out about a week ago I
did my best to avoid getting to this
story but I think we actually have to
get to it the clip is all over the place
and I've I've censored it liberally so
that you don't have to hear too much of
this gross lesson this is a high school
teacher in Southern California giving a
lesson on pleasing
an orifice of the body
you don't have to go inside
you can actually just push on the scene
and that stimulates the land as well and
that all they apparently really like
that
um but yeah so that's why for male and
male
this is still very pleasurable because
of the fact that it hits the it hits and
there's a lot of nerve endings in your
beauty as well so the girls
prostate they're the equivalent to each
other but apparently that's why if you
ever see like
I become target has them now sex toys if
you go to Target seriously if you go to
Target and go over to tampons and
patterns they have they just look like a
little box but if you open up there's
like a velcro front to the Box you open
it up and then bam sex toy okay you get
the idea there's more to the video but
you you can use your imagination to fill
in the blanks and what else you're
saying she's giving the students this
very graphic
instructive lesson
on how to engage in deviant sexual
practices that are not oriented towards
say the good of the spouses and the
generation in the education of children
traditionally understood as the T loss
of sexual relations the purpose of
sexual relations but on how to titillate
people in ways by putting things where
they're not supposed to go so
some parents are up in arms about this
the teacher has been placed on
administrative leave
but students are defending the teacher
a student said quote
as a student in the video I would like
to say that everything taught by our
teacher is educational this is an
anatomy physiology class
and people shouldn't put her on leave
and she should be rehired and I got to
tell you oddly enough
I'm with the students
I'm kind of on the teacher's side here
this is a gross lesson it obviously
shouldn't be taught in high schools it
obviously shouldn't be taught a taxpayer
expense the kids are getting a bad
education here the woman is
bad at her job if her job is educating
people
but she's pretty good at her job if her
job is following the lesson plans that
her bosses set out
the woman is just doing the job that was
established by the school boards by the
state now when we're talking about
California
and by our culture more broadly
she's teaching a class on anatomy and
physiology we have classes on sexual
education
sexual education now no longer has a
moral aspect to it
in the traditional sense I guess it has
a moral aspect to it in the in the
immoral modern sense which is to say any
sexual behavior that you find
pleasurable is good that's a that's a
moral lesson it just happens to be
immoral and it teaches the the
immorality of liberalism rather than the
true morality of religion but
she's just following the lesson man
don't fire her
she's doing her job you should fire the
school board members you should in the
case of California you should fire the
state administrators over education and
the governor Gavin Newsom
but we can't get mad at the foot
soldiers for following the orders
if if you get mad at that you should say
maybe she should quit her job or
she probably doesn't know any better
the people who really deserve our ire
are the people who are setting the
lessons
and that includes the governors
that includes the state administrators
and that includes
the number of people often a very vocal
intense activist minority but sometimes
there's a significant number of them
people ordinary citizens who peddle this
stuff this is wrong if you don't want it
in your schools then you've got to vote
the bums out and then when whenever and
wherever you can wield political power
to take the power away from these
weirdos right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles one company that I'm very proud
to stand behind a company that's proud
to stand behind us in our country
Pure Talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless provider of
the daily wire but that is not the only
reason
Pure Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the US they're
a top tier provider and a fraction of
the cost of those other companies you
know those companies ATT Verizon
T-Mobile
companies that do not care about you or
what you believe mix and match your
plans to fit every person in your family
choose from talk text and 5G data for
just 20 bucks a month all the way up to
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot
just 55 a month I guarantee that's less
than you're paying for that right now
you vote with how you spend your money
stop supporting woke wireless companies
that do not support you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you get great
coverage and save while you're doing it
go to puretalk.com Knowles you'll save
an additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that is
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
buy Americans for Americans right now go
to preparewithknowles.com I'd love that
URL in a world filled with uncertainty
it is crucial to be ready for whatever
comes your way whether that's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is offering major savings on
their popular four-week emergency food
kit to help you stay prepared for
anything go to prepare with knowles.com
grab this special price before it ends
that your four week emergency food kit
provides over 2 000 calories each day
for optimal strength and energy in
stressful situations you can enjoy a
wide variety of my Patriot Supply and
can customize your supply they offer an
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meat and even a
gluten-free kit the best part is each
meal is delicious has a shelf life of 25
years do not wait for disaster to strike
before taking action invest in your
safety and well-being by securing your
food storage today prepare with
knowles.com get major savings on your
four week emergency supply kit prepare
with knowles.com prepare with
knowles.com
there's this case
Holland versus brackeen I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing that this is a challenge
the 1978 Indian Child Welfare act which
was created to maintain Native American
culture by prioritizing native families
in the adoption of native children
and the case was 7-2
the only people who voted
against the claims of the Indian tribes
to keep the kids even if the kids are
had been adopted by non-indian parents
the only ones to vote against that were
Alito and Thomas who were the two most
conservative judges on the court
the other the libs plus the other
conservatives they voted in favor of the
Indian Child Welfare Act
which prioritizes maintaining Native
American culture over the interests of
the Native American children
and obviously over the interests of the
non-native American families who have
adopted these children and there are all
sorts of legal rights that were involved
in in this decision
uh 10th Amendment rights you know states
rights the 14th Amendment right to equal
protection but
at a broader level this case
is a debate between liberalism and
Christian conservatism
because if you've got to debate
if you are on the side of liberalism
classical or otherwise if you were on
the side of nationalism which which
crops up at the same time as liberalism
this idea that Nations have a pretty
firmly absolute right to do whatever the
hell they want within their own
territories within their among their own
people if you believe that there are
plenty of conservatives who believe that
and they're sort of persuasive arguments
then you're going to side with the
Indians here you're going to side with
the Indian Child Welfare act you're
going to say the maintenance of Indian
culture feather not DOT is more
important than the welfare of any
individual Indian Child
however if you are on the side of
Christian conservatism you're going to
side with the Indian children here
against the Indian Child Welfare Act
because if you're on the side of
Christian conservatism you're probably
sympathetic to the particular claims of
a particular tribe and you you're not
opposed to them having their own culture
and traditions and practices but
more fundamentally you believe that
there are Eternal truths
you believe that you are called to
evangelize all of the Nations
and you believe that
your understanding of the truth
has a special claim all throughout the
world
that we're not just going to live in
some relativistic hodgepodge of
individual cultures and Nations and you
can't judge my culture and I can't judge
your culture and stay out of my borders
man
if you're a traditional Christian
conservative conservative you're going
to say oh no
there is a God he's a Triune God he
loves us
we have the gospel message we've got a
good culture here and so we're not
necessarily going to be eager to go in
and Conquer you or you know make we're
not going to make you convert at
gunpoint or anything like that but if a
Native American family puts their kid up
for adoption we have to raise that kid
we baptized that kid then we are going
to continue to raise that kid and your
claims of cultural particularity or
whatever are not going to overcome the
claims of baptism and the gospel and the
the Western culture Christendom that
we're going to raise this child in
and you're going to see conservatives
fall on both sides of this
there are plenty of strong conservative
Defenders of nationalism even even of
Classical liberalism to some degree
but it is no coincidence that the I the
people who appear to be the most
conservative and I think the most
conservative and a Christian
conservative kind of way Alito and
Thomas they're the ones who come down on
the side of the kids
the others who are a little bit
a little bit more liberal a little bit
less hardcore they're the ones who side
with the actual Court liberals and and
side with the the Indian tribes boy what
a great clip that was huh if you want
the whole show including the stuff we're
not allowed to talk about on here you
know like a certain issue that we're not
allowed to talk about head on over to
daily wire
plus.com right now and also head and
check out the Michael Knowles show at
Twitter M Knowles show we'll see you
there